will and chad huey lewis and the news is
your favorite band
their most successful album sports was
released september 15 1983. i have
supplied you with a list of events that
the human race found to be significant
in that year
you must now use this astonishing list
to describe these events in the style of
various huey lewis songs this is dude z
lewis and the news begin okay okay dude
this is [ __ ] we did something kind of
like this yeah
some some manner of episodes ago dudesy
told us that we had to sing songs about
the 90s in the style of pearl jam pearl
jam so this is going to be songs about
[ __ ] that happened in 1983 in the style
and there's a list in the news which
by the way dude you know what my first
concert was ever when i was 10 years old
what she was loose in the news was it
really yeah my parents took me to it and
it was also the first time that i had
hard alcohol
um oh yeah you've told me the story what
the [ __ ] happened again i was really
thirsty and one of their friends that
was with them just was like here dude
take a drink of this and it was like
jack and coke or something and you're 10
year old [ __ ] kid thirsty i just
guzzled like half of it and then uh was
this the same dude who went to the
movies with you and your dad and that's
a different guy what did that guy say
that was total recall yeah and this guy
i remember the whole ride there just
kept going get ready for the ride of
your life he said that phrase probably
like 40 [ __ ] times because that was
in the in the promo yeah it was in like
some tv commercials or something get
ready for the ride of your life that
would have been and you were like 12
years old that would have been the
funniest [ __ ] thing
in the world huey lewis in the news
sports was one of those albums along
with uh van halen 1984 and weird al
yankovic in 3d that i
wore that tape out wore that [ __ ]
tape out
so i didn't quite do that but i do
remember being at a
flea market thing with a girlfriend many
years ago
and her parents went to this evangelical
church and it was like a christian flea
market and somebody was selling tapes
that had done christian parodies of
songs no yeah and there was one for huey
lewis and the only line in it that i
remember was
you don't need no credit card to praise
his name
all right
so anyone has provided uh
uh
a bunch of uh in a [ __ ] minute dudesy
has provided a bunch of uh things from
1983 that uh i guess it thinks that
human beings would find interesting also
here's a track listing uh from doodzy uh
from uh huey lewis in the news uh sports
the heart of rock and roll heart and
soul remember that bad is bad i want a
new drug of course
walking on a thin line finally found a
home if this is it
then you crack me up and then the last
song is honky tonk if this is it
please let me know
i don't know
this will be fun and because i like to
go
because it seems like this with his arms
and if you look at me right now it looks
like a milk and cows are grabbing [ __ ]
and we got just a few things to to
discuss here a few of the events of 1983
super mario brothers arcade game came
out nintendo uh first computer was sold
in japan it's a family computer known as
the famicom yeah i do stupid name
okay what else u.s invades granada
motorola releases the first mobile phone
that's pretty big interesting uh ar ar
pen ar panet the advanced research
the advanced research project the
projects agency network and the defense
data network officially changed the tc
it changed to the tcp ip standard giving
birth to the internet internet started
yeah all networks can now be connected
by your universal language i did not
know that started in 1983. got the
cabbage patch kids coming out we got
swatch watches coming out do you have a
swatch watch i did okay microsoft word
oh look at this chad you like this
crack cocaine mix it into the u.s yep uh
no i was gonna say mcdonald's introduces
the mcnuggets oh yeah hey hey guys say
hey hey everybody that's kind of like
crack okay hey a guy like crack okay
right
yeah dude one or two of those kids but
you can't bite just one alice walker won
the pulitzer for the color purple
a 12 year old swim across the english
channel that's [ __ ] insane ronald
reagan did some [ __ ] oh he announces
that president ronald reagan announces
that gps will be made available to the
public though it was originally intended
for military use only lowest temperature
ever recorded uh was in a russian
antarctica base called vostok it went to
minus 89.2 celsius minus 128. that's
[ __ ] cool
christ
look
what okay dudes he's having some fun
with us here it says the squeen family
moved to ladner british columbia from
saskatoon saskatchewan all right uh the
3d printer is invented by chuck hall in
1983 and it hasn't really gained
popularity until the past couple years
here
and adam driver is born on november 19th
let's get through the rest of some of
these tv shows that showed up in 83 the
a-team wheel of fortune reading rainbow
fraggle rock he-man and the masters of
the universe mama's family and mash
final episode drew 125 million viewers
look at the movies chad return to the
jedi flash dance risky business national
anthony's vacation strange brew trading
places yep well it was a different time
brother gandhi wins eight of 11 oscar
noms hold on a second chad you got to
know that when gandhi won
8 out of 11 academy awards
that's the award they call the oscars
dude not to be confused with the
slammy's brother because that's what the
wrestling awards are dude is that real
salamis yeah dude the slammy awards
and they don't do it every year anymore
brother but back in the day they did and
they had the jesse the body award and i
remember when rick rude won the jesse
the body award and i thought that was
cool yeah but then when he went up in
front of my hulk maniacs stripped down i
decided right then and there not only am
i gonna beat you one two three in the
middle of the ring ravishing rickroot
i'm gonna snap your skinny arms and your
skinny legs
probably wouldn't have been able to do
that to uh rick rude probably not he was
a bit of a tough guy so we also had
michael jackson coming out thriller that
year madonna's madonna quiet riot we had
kiss police brian adams and dave
mustaine leaves metallica to start
megadeth that year that's kind of
interesting okay
and uh the who announces that the group
is disbanding uh which they got back
together for
live aid two years later so who cares oh
and in sports we got the pine tar
incident john elway goes number one in
the draft to the baltimore colts then
being traded to the denver broncos hulk
hogan is resigned by the wwf
vince mcmahon makes him his centerpiece
of the uh changed your life forever
changed my life forever uh this would
have been after he was thunder lips and
rocky iii yeah which did that come out
this year no came out the year before
anyway all right okay so we got to come
up with these songs let's say that i
want a new drug as a big candidate i
think that's probably his most famous
song or one of them or the power of love
yeah but there's also gotta get back in
time right it's not from sports but who
cares or if this is it
that's a good one
uh doing it all for my babe all right so
anyway there's a lot of happy to be
stuck with you happy to be
with you
got the same
food on
all the same friends
and the
[Laughter]
uh okay so what do we start okay the
heart of rocking well i'd say the heart
of rock and roll is still beating
super mario gamers arcade game but then
it got changed into nintendo they put
out a family computer that's known as
the famicom that went on sale in japan
not a good song
we're not starting off strong
here that was real [ __ ] good what do
you what uh what up okay name a song uh
let's get the do i want a new drug
okay i want a new drug
it tucks well doozy uh has given us the
fact that crack cocaine made its way to
the united states maybe not that drunk
that's a little drug one that's called
crack cocaine
cocaine ramen crack cocaine
eddie i made it to keep impoverished
populations down
and it rhymes with crack cocaine that's
pretty good dude
no
um
the motorola comes up with the first no
no no
i don't like it
uh
how about i want a new i want a new
phone i want a new phone
one that don't have a card
i want a new phone one that don't have a
card
uh what the what
what what else should it be what do you
think i mean
i want a new phone one that don't have a
card
one that weighs around five pounds and
that no one can afford
it
right because it was expensive and large
yeah i want a new phone
so i can have an affair
oh i want a new phone so i can have an
affair
what you can use in my car
talk to people everywhere
now we're cooking with gas yeah i love
that but that's not in the kitchen
one is just for me
one that i don't share one that i don't
have to share with my family
[Music]
[ __ ] my family
hey [ __ ] my family yeah what i want
that's a good one
you got that one well no it's called i
want a new phone oh i'd call it [ __ ] my
family
how about this parentheses [ __ ] my
family this this song is called i want a
new phone and then in parentheses [ __ ]
my family yeah i want a new phone
one that don't have a card
one that weighs around five pounds that
people can't afford
i want a new phone so i can have an
affair
talk to people in my car or [ __ ] use
it anywhere
what is that in the kitchen
one is just for me
one that i don't have to share with my
family
[ __ ] my family
that's good
what else we got
i just like the family i like the
premise in that song that you [ __ ]
get this five pound giant [ __ ] brick
that cost ten thousand dollars to have
an affair yeah but somehow that's more
efficient i would like to know maybe
dudesy can hip us to this the uh the
divorce rate
i wonder if that went up and down yeah
after the cell phone well it's been
going up steadily since uh divorce was
introduced what's that in the kitchen
what is it for me
one that i don't have to share with my
family
[ __ ] my family
like my
two kids from a previous marriage that
my wife had with her first husband paul
barron
i don't like paul very much
and he made his kids too tall
my kids don't look like me okay what
else do we got what else do we get what
other ones are here yeah right on a thin
line adam driver being born i think is
is something something with maybe adam
driver and
[ __ ] i don't know what's uh i always
like that i'm happy to be stuck with you
uh yeah what is that uh we we've had our
doubts
and down yeah and adam driver
well i saw him and girls
that's the first time
that's the first time i taught him act
and i and he did him and lena
[Laughter]
it was the show with lena dunham
then i saw him in star wars
and the
marriage story with
rachel mcadams right yeah
no it was uh scarlett joe scarlet joe
henson
same thing yeah and i'm stuck
i don't know man uh i first saw him and
girls
i've only seen two episodes
lena dunham gets on my nerves
and i no longer have hbo
what's that show on hbo
are you i don't remember what girls was
on
then i saw him in house of gucci
with lady
gaga
and yes it's true
he was in house of gucci too
yes it's true
he was in
okay he also played abraham
oh thank you moving on terrific we got a
couple of good ones out of that
here's what you do
please tell a friend then brave and
brave
[Music]
[Music]
then